hey what up it's j Stone you already
know what's cracking man we out here we
outside man shout out to Bole care we
out here on the podcast West
West all right yo man bootle C podcast
special guest in here his new album
drops November 22nd yes sir the
definition of success definition of
success and this ends the series yeah
this the final chapter um how many is it
four or five albums it's four yeah this
is the fourth the four yeah well the
fourth
so this is the fourth definition yeah
but like probably like the six or seven
projects since I you know what I mean
since yeah yeah yeah uh we got J Stone
in the building man welcome yeah man I'm
in here man what's up K welcome back man
man come on man welcome back it's a new
plaque I yeah we got a new spot man we
in here um hey so talk to me like for
you why was it time to kind of like put
a a bow on the series cuz you're kind of
known for the definition series like
it's something that kind of started gave
you the original idea facts um why why
put a bow on it why was it time um I
just felt like you know this is the time
you know a point in time in my life you
feel me where I'm on some different [__]
bro I ain't thinking the same I lyrics
ain't the same you feel me like I'm on
some success [__] bro this is this is
the time now you feel me like so that's
just what I'm on um I somehow feel like
when we talk about La rap you're always
overlooked yeah man when they mention La
rap man they need to mention me more you
feel me I feel like they don't and and
and I always tell this to people like
you've done such a great job of like
uh like kind of just flying under the
radar becoming a millionaire off of a
independent catalog like doing [__] that
most rappers can't do yeah dropping when
you want yeah and I'm you know I'm good
with that you feel me like I don't
really need I don't really need like
props from the majors or none of that
because I'm solidified already you feel
me like real [__] [__] with me
you know what I mean like the real cats
in the industry [__] with me bro like so
at the end of the day it's like I ain't
really looking for no validation but at
the same time it's like don't forget
about me I'm over here running these
crazy laps you feel me yeah and you
you're like a um very much like you know
um at this point man like in LA Hip Hop
you're you're a figure man like yeah man
don't count me out count me in for sure
like add that up y'all did the wrong
total add that up burn money don't work
over here man count that over you feel
me I was going to say for you was there
ever any um opportunities that came up
that you passed on or that you didn't
decide to go with when it comes to like
maybe taking a direction or step in the
direction of being more on a major
situation or a bigger distribution
situation yeah damn near um you know I
didn't sat I didn't sat with labels bro
I didn't sat with uh I sat with Rock
Nation you know I mean I sat down with
rap a
lot out to lot yeah for sure shout out
to Trey you know I mean shout out to J
Prince I sat down we had a conversation
we talked about the vision you feel me
and he asked me like what I wanted to do
he was ready to do everything that I
wanted to do you feel me but like
whoever kind of was like middleman in
the situation I don't think he knew like
that they was you know talking the way
that they was talking cuz I had a
conversation with J Prince so that was
the conversation we had when I talked to
the you know the middleman and all that
you feel me so it was just something
different you feel me so I just chose to
stay independent you know what I mean
until I can holler at the boss man you
feel me myself on the boss man tip yeah
no I mean that I think that's cuz what
you are you doing to core drro kid how
you putting out your [__] right now man
I'm strictly independent man it's 258 no
breaks man no but you got to obviously
you got to get the music out of course
so like what service do you use I don't
use no service I am the service man so
you don't have it I'm putting my [__]
out man so you're putting your [__]
directly on the dsps yeah oh okay that's
great N I ain't doing it myself but you
know I don't want to give away well no
cuz like a lot cuz like you know for
people who don't know there's like Dr
kid and ton Corp which in my opinion
make it very easy to be independent no
for show let me not cap pay producers
shout out to Toon Core though shout out
to Toon Core I've been rocking with them
since day one you're still fully
independent all you're doing is paying
them a one time fee yeah and giving and
giving everybody what they title too you
can do splits right exactly you can do
that now yeah cuz that's the one thing
is like when you're an independent
artist I'm sure it can get really really
like yeah overwhelming to make sure the
producer gets taken care producers got
to get taken care of
theit anybody that had anything to do
let me break you off here's your points
yeah for sure yeah but you know but
that's what the majors don't do you know
yeah they rather they rather they rather
buy your percentages out they rather
give you a nice check rather like dick
you around as if you're a writer or a
producer there's a reason you can get
the same you can get the percentages but
not get the money and it takes forever
yeah you know I just saw internet money
uh the dude who runs internet money was
saying like I'm going to start calling
some of these major labels out cuz you
guys are over a year pass do on some of
my producers like fees like it's like
these after a while you look around and
you be like man the numbers don't add up
some ain't adding up the numbers ain't
adding up you feel me but like when you
when you don't see that dashboard when
you really don't see the actual numbers
and where they going you know they say
numbers don't lie that's a lie numbers
lie
too for you do you notice like um cuz I
always try to look you know I talked to
pero about this a little bit but he's
like look now that I'm independent and
I'm off Rock Nation he's been leveling
up because he could drop whenever he
wants and he was like now when I drop
it's almost like the stock market like I
put some new [__] out and everything
else spikes up like the rest of my
catalog go up yeah so that's the beauty
of it just keep on being cons consist
you can't just drop a project and then
wait two three years and drop another
project like that's why I really didn't
want to tell nobody cuz you know
[__] be you know watching how I
do my little [__] yeah you feel me but I
ain't going to lie as soon as a ball
drop I drop January 1st I'm dropping a
project February 14th I'm dropping
another project March whenever I'm
dropping another project like right
you've been on it bro I'm dropping 12
albums next year bro so next year 12
albums one each month how much music
right now are you sitting
on um unlimited bro I can't even really
imagine how much music I got cuz I still
got old stuff from me and nip we did
back in the day in 2006 and Beyond you
feel me what do you do like you like
what do you do with that with those
records uh do we just do you just keep
them is there a time and a place always
had conversations about just you know
running the music up first running up
what we got now and then you know just
build that catalog and then like
introduce them to the old [__] but that
was when I didn't have a crazy catalog
you feel me so right it's now yeah I got
a crazy catalog now so we can kind of
like bring up them old uh Myspace
mixtapes and crazy yeah you know what I
mean a lot of that unreleased [__] so
yeah yeah I was going to say uh for you
like uh you know we talked about the LA
conversation who are some of the upand
cominging LA artists that are outside of
the camp that you're just a fan of that
you're just like yo I see what you're
doing there's there's so many new guys
that are doing their thing um
x4's I ain't going to cap I'm going give
it to uh z s right now cuz you know a
lot of [__] don't want to
mention his name they don't want to
really they real numbers yeah you feel
me and I know they I know yeah I know
they see little bro you feel me but they
going to act like they don't that's what
they do you feel me they going to wait
to something big happen and everybody
else is on to it and then they gonna
want to [__] with him but hey he does
have the song underrated for a reason
cuz he is an underrated guy it's like
crazy like he's doing numbers that like
most artists aren't doing feeling like
that underrated [__] be like an
understatement mhm yeah for sure yeah no
zo's dope have you guys got to work at
all nah but we be chopping it up about
doing music you know what I mean he's a
good kid man it ain't nothing to do
nothing you feel me that's easy man yeah
that's easy you feel me we had try the
truth up here a couple of weeks ago and
he had alluded to the fact that you guys
have an unreleased project somewhere
yeah we got we got me and Trey got music
yeah yeah me and Tre got I didn't
realize cuz he was telling us like how
he has like unreleased albums with so
many people and I was just like damn
like that's one [__] I know that
his work ethnic is crazy bro like he'll
drop a project shoot on his phone he's
like bro I got an album with this person
everybody I don't know if you heard like
you know cuz he do the Amon like you
know he he got he got the series of that
[__] you feel me I think he's working on
a new one I don't think you heard that
one bro no he didn't play me that one
but he played me some other [__] he
played me some crazy [__] you should
have had him play you that the latest
I'm on he been that see I'm I'm saying
too no he talked about it a little bit
bro he got every he he got a lot of
[__] on there bro I almost want
to get on that [__] you should
[__] someone should do like a West Coast
version of that try to unify the city
put everybody that's what I'm saying we
need to do something cuz we ain't really
got too much going on out here like that
you feel me I think we need another uh
not a uh we are the world but uh n we
did something like that for La what's
that record that ice cube did I mean e
did with uh he did with uh yoyo he deal
with everybody like all the rappers I
feel me yeah be [__] 10 minute song
10 minute song bro everybody the
politics throw the politics out window I
you too we bringing you back outside you
too cuz I know you got something to say
spit some game to these youngsters man
they need it now I think it'd be dope
too cuz like you said like you know I
think big sea did something like that he
had a bunch of people he did the Detroit
freestyle or Cipher and it had yeah
there was like 12 Detroit rappers and
like a lot of them that was on his
latest album right but did he do a video
to it no but because a lot of the guys
had issues with each other but at the
end of the day it was kind of dope cuz
you you might have heard songs two guys
on a song that you would have heard
before that you would have never heard
before yeah 100% man but see only like
people like Big Sean can do that
everybody can't you know what I mean
everybody don't got pulled like that in
their City you feel me so it got to be
somebody that you know the city respect
that should have be hard yeah there's
the idea someone go execute it all right
there it is who's on the new album any
features on the
album yeah we got some features on the
album we got uh who we got on the album
man I got uh I got Nick bucks shout out
to Nick Buck hard hey he just got shot
too right I think yeah I think hope he's
good man shout out to my yeah I talked
to him good yeah great great dude we
went to Harlem and hung out with him
yeah yeah real [__] man for sure I got
a song with him I got a record with uh
Bun B and Trey oh feel me on the same
record yeah on htown V I'm always out
there so you know gotta show my little
la htown love you feel me um who else I
got domm you don't know I got DM you
feel me DM and me ni Hit Boy and uh BH
really yeah big hit yeah wait no hit boy
well you said I thought you said BH yeah
BH oh you think I'm thinking big head
yeah no Boss Hog yeah I got a record
with him too I got a record with big H
yeah big hit going in yeah hey I like
that energy how [__] can just
come home and just act like you ain't
even been to jail like you ain't did no
time bro and his son got all the ill
beats ready to just ready to bro that
remind me of how I was when I was fresh
out you know what I mean like I hit the
ground running I think too it's
inspiring cuz it's like no matter what
situation you're put in like it ain't
never too late to like nah it's never
too late yeah like homie this is second
like cuz I remember this is second go at
the rap game in terms of like us seeing
him cuz you know when man a lot of
billionaires didn't get their billion
until they was about 40 50 that's facts
you know what I mean so it it don't
limit yourself doing nothing man I don't
think nobody should ever limit their
self doing nothing you feel you got to
keep this [__] going cuz you never know
you never know man like most like you
said most people kind of hit that
success stride in their 40s or 50s yeah
and then you got to you got to you know
you got to kind of take your situation
and kind of look at it too like maybe he
had to go through that to to get to the
mental space to where he could win yeah
exactly now now now now look where his
look where his focus at now you feel me
so tell me about this record it's you
nip produced by hit booy produced by hit
boy o yeah it's on the album it's on the
album I'm I'm lowkey ready to drop that
right now you feel me but you know I I I
I'll let y'all wait for it man let y'all
press was this a record you guys uh cuz
always had heard about the hit boy nip
SE I think it was like the session that
racks in the middle was recorded uh what
was this something you guys worked on
when he was alive around that time yeah
this something that we worked on um in
2018 you feel me and
um you know we just spice up the beat
just a little bit right you know what I
mean cuz it's 2023 now of course so you
know we made it make sense I really
excited anytime we got new nip coming n
for sure I know last time uh when you
came on the show you had uh dropped
tidbits that may or may not have gotten
you in trouble about there being a nipsy
Hustle N it didn't get me in trouble but
that [__] hit the blog that sh it went
everywhere and and then I was just only
and then there was people who were like
yeah right he's lying like I'm like bro
like if he anybody would know it might
be him like yeah you feel me like come
on man like and then all I said was like
bro got so much music like I'm pretty
sure it's for sure going to be another
nip album is update there I mean [__]
what you think bro you don't think it's
going to be has to be another nip Alum
come on man cuz like you said you he has
so much unreleased music it just has to
be done the right way that's the only
thing is like yeah it ain't going to get
put out just cuz cuz you because you
know right cuz I almost think like when
Pac passed there was like a couple of
them albums that were rough yo we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie that's right man it
is betting season right now we got
football we got basketball NBA is
underway that boy Wana is looking crazy
put all your money on him to win Rookie
of the Year all right do it at my bookie
right now go to my bookie all right when
you sign up at my bookie use the promo
code bootle use that promo code right
now and you're going to get a no
strings cash bonus that's right put your
deposit in withdraw the free cash up to
$200 right away I mean even if you don't
want to bet create an account get an
extra $200 take it out keep it moving
moving all right but look right now
football season is getting into the
thick of it all right I feel like the
playoff picture is going to start to
really kind of become a lot more clear
soon all right yo shout out to the
Bengals Bengals is finally getting it
together my Cardinals look like absolute
dog [__] which is what I love
nonetheless you could bet every single
weekend on my bookie this is what's up
about my bookie you can do your daily
odds boosts your same game parlays and
the crazy huge prize pool contest use
that promo code right now on your first
deposit so when you sign up with the new
account your very first deposit use the
promo code bootleg this is important cuz
you're going to get up to $200 in cash
when you use that promo code bootleg
claim your cash bonus right now no
strings attached deposit withdraw quick
there's so much going on man try the
mybookie money bag to grab a potential
Super Bro front runner at Long Shot odds
plus 38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs man
is crazy you can bet anything anytime
anywhere they got the full service
casino going down slots roulette
whatever it is if you're into it you can
gamble it you can bet it my bookie sign
up with that promo code bootleg right
now also got to give a big shout out to
the homies at my well I already said my
bookie [__] new commercial shout out to
the homies over at bluechew man that's
right bluechew everybody always ask me
does bluechew work well you don't take
my word for it try it for free for a
month by using that promo code bootleg
right now blueo has the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Calis uh it's
all wrapped up into a blue chewable form
delivered right to your doorstep in
discreet packaging no doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blu.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
you're dick ain't [__] it's time to
get a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with a little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some Su to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue chw
baby blue chw try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
free a month supply for free go to
blu.com use the promo code bootleg right
now thank me later let's get back to the
interview but the first like one or two
do you remember me and then um the one
that had uh the the the the acoustic uh
thugs mansion on it was hard oh uh which
which one was it better days was fire
yeah better days had some [__] but then
there was like the [__] that like he was
working with like artists he would have
never have worked with when he was alive
yeah bro like um what was that uh he had
like a song with Eminem and uh bro
Eminem did the whole album bro he
produced he weird and
because you bro you had to get used used
to hearing Pac on Eminem beat it was
more like some mashup like [__] yeah
that's right it was that's that's that's
all it was you know what I mean like I'm
a Pac fan I'm an Eminem fan you know
what I mean but to hear Pac on an Eminem
beat bro it just kind of it wasn't I
wasn't ready I wasn't ready for it it it
was a little weird for sure it'd be like
if it would have been dope if like some
of the OG producers Pac was working with
came and took some of those stems yeah
curated something like did it the right
way Dazz in to do some production you
know what I'm saying that's the right
way to do it Superfly bring DH Superfly
in there you feel me should maybe Dre
yeah you feel me and then yeah Dre can
do the mixing even quick too call Quick
in you feel me quick G come on man quick
could have did that whole hour oh that
would have been crazy and it would have
been more it would have been more like
uh you know it would have sounded like a
Tupac album n it definitely would have
sound with quick and uh the dog pound on
like crazy for sure man yo it's crazy
too like obviously you're a big poac fan
thug life
too uh uh it's kind of crazy to see
there's finally like all these years
later someone got arrested for his death
what's that Tupac's death man that [__]
crazy bro and then we still don't even
know yeah we still don't even know what
to believe man you know what me I mean
and that's the thing is like it feels I
mean look as like a fan I mean you don't
want to ever see anybody go to jail yeah
but like but why but why so long though
like thing is is that this that's why
that's that's what seemed tricky is like
you've been hearing the same story all
along all along all along like why y'all
wait 30 this guy was doing all these
interviews and he been doing interview
when they eventually I think I think
he's done so many interviews that it had
to have finally like come across like
bro yeah your time Las Vegas Metro like
like radar where they're like wait this
guy's wait what like we should go see if
this cuz cuz I I always tell people like
the Tupac they probably pinched him you
know what I mean just
to get some more just to get some more
information
and and to me the Tupac and Biggie
murders were very different like the
Tupac murder was some retaliation [__]
that really wasn't didn't have it was
some Street [__] that that popped off in
one night as opposed to like the biggie
[__] was like a hit and depending on who
you listen to like the LAPD off duty
cops might have been involved like I
don't think the LAPD wanted to solve the
biggie murder because it would have made
them look crazy the Tupac murder was
just
like you know Orlando Anderson died and
that was who everybody was saying it was
the you know the guy behind it so this
dude's been doing all these interviews
[__] got to stop self snitching
bro yeah this [__] crazy bro like people
just just just people literally snitch
on themselves just for the views man for
real it's crazy you se you seen that
interview with no jumper when he asked
uh yeah ask for that question he
said he's like all right so I mean you
know he didn't know how to handle it
after that he he he was supposed to come
on the show uh earlier this morning but
um we
rescheduled I didn't know cuz he I
didn't know I had him come early CU I
don't I don't know La politics I don't
know if you guys get along I don't know
n it's all good you feel me no but you
know I I don't know if if I ever have
two La rappers in the same
day [__] the Earth is my turf I love
that you know what I mean I go anywhere
I walk anywhere if I run it or whoever
it's going to be what it's going to be
if it's respect it respect if it ain't
it ain't you know what I mean that clip
uh was very funny though you see that
clip yeah X4 was just like Adam asked
him if he was involved in some shootout
on a video and he just looked at him
like this yeah I like damn and I think
you've shown like um I gave you props
last time like when you and trell did
that interview on no jumper that was
like a big deal yeah for sure I went I
went out of town I was somewhere out of
town I ran into one his homies and [__]
he like yeah man I'm from hu man I seen
that video you did with my homie you
feel me think that [__] should be like
an example for the Young Generation so
you see like the the the difference and
a respect level you feel me like yeah I
think like cuz I told him I'm like you
know [__] either going to hate
it or love it he like both yeah he like
they going to hate it or they going to
love it you know what I mean like it is
what it is but so what you feel me yeah
I just think it's like it's it's
important to be able to show people like
you know we can break the cycle and some
of my homies knew who he was like when I
let the homies know like you feel me
like they who he was I mean show shout
out to T yeah man you know great guy
salute um so next year for sure 12
albums for sure already already put it
see one thing about me once I put out
all right so I got my January album
ready okay so that's ready mix and
master ready so we're going from
November 22nd to the January album
straight into the January album damn you
ain't playing yeah and I thought about
I'm like damn I need to give you know
success some time to bre you feel me
tour shows and all that but like you
know with the game right now bro the
year it's going to be a new year yeah
music industry kind of resets for people
who don't know that's what I'm saying so
it's really all on like who going who
going who going to go to hardest soon is
a bar drop so that's why I say when the
bar drop I drop feel me January 1st oh
that's when the albums dropping yeah oh
[__] okay right away right away bro no I
ain't giving nobody no room bro no
Breathing Room bro I'm not playing I
love it yeah 25 a no brace for real man
in the flesh I love it man for you have
you um obviously nip uh you guys just
did a uh a dope show was it at the Roxy
you guys all did uh the the was it Roxy
or LR L is a little bit more bigger than
a Roxy I was say it was either Roxy or
LR we was going to originally do it at
the Roxy but um it would have been too
small exactly we need we needed a little
bit more expansion but obviously he was
so good at like curating artists
bringing you know artist on to the to
the team is that something you want to
do as well put the co hat on eventually
and definitely Talent um for sure you
know like I said you know when when the
when the when the year drop I'm also
going to announce you know what I mean a
couple of my artists oh so you've
already done that I've been doing music
with yeah cuz you know they they G to
drop too so I'm and is that a is that
258 it's 258 yeah no breaks for sure so
I got I got a good I got I got some good
management going on some marketing you
feel me
PRS yeah we locked in man feel me I'm to
take this label [__] to another level
yeah you had to have learned so much too
just being around everybody you've been
around to where you can kind of like
apply so much of the game that you've
gotten over the years yeah you got to
think about it like we grew up we grew
up we grew up watching you know the
master pe's you know what I mean the the
the uh the easy EAS the Su nights the J
the pr you feel what I'm saying like
they had a CEO mentality you feel what
I'm saying that's why I just did the uh
the soundtrack for the movie Bon P I
just saw that yeah exactly so you know I
grew up you know death R all the
soundtracks what Above the Rim Min
Society come on bro I don't even know
what's going on with soundtracks anymore
cuz soundtracks back in the day that's
what I'm saying so I'm trying to bring
that back you feel me like we got a good
La movie going on all right let me put
some la music behind it you feel me let
me make the soundtrack for it let me
grab some artist from here from there
make a yeah Cate a whole soundtrack n
that's dope I mean [__] the last time
someone did that and killed it I think
was black panther black panther Ken
Lamar killed that man shout out that was
a good album had s so RB on there oh
yeah Mazy was on there Mazy was on there
I'm like oh yeah we looking good yes and
that was like 2017 or 18 to like so like
it was I was like finally mazy's getting
like a look and that was like that was
like it wasn't a Kendrick More album but
that was like it was about as much when
he didn't put out an album you had to be
like all right that was it was kind of
like Eminem's 8 Mile it was like it was
kind of like M this about as close to
Eminem albums you can get like
Kendrick's fingerprints all over the
album that a Mile soundtrack was crazy
boy all right man also want to give a
shout out to our family over at King pom
baby you already know man we always stay
King pomed up over here it's the only
thing we're smoking you know what I love
about King pom so many
flavors so natural organic tobac e free
leaves this is how we're smoking at the
bootleg Kev podcast and um like let me
just say this dude like all shapes and
sizes you know what I mean like just
give you a little variation of the type
of King Pals you can get down with you
know just different shapes different
sizes
natural organic tobacc free a clean
smoke if you will so many the this is
the honey berry which might be my new
favorite I do love the uh the energy
drink one the red rain is fire all all
right um but listen if you want to get
down with some of these King Palms trust
me when I say man they are the best way
to smoke um first of all you can go to
your local liquor store 711 all that
they got King poms all right so go pick
something up or you can go to their
website now if you go to their website
King pom.com go to King pom.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and uh you
can say 50% off at King pom.com half off
whatever you want what are we
smoking this is the uh the Orange Swirl
what's dope about King pal is they have
like the flavor the tarpine infused tips
so like let's say you got this one right
you got some of that Orange Swirl you
feel
me you load it up put your wheat in
there or whatever your
tobacco and then in the tip you press
down on that thing and you're getting
hit with all that
flavor all right so go to uh King
pom.com use the promo code bootleg right
now get half off or just go to your
local liquor store go to your local
7-Eleven and run it up with some King
Palms also want to give a shout out to
our family at odd Soxs man don't forget
get you some odd Sox in your life go to
oddsocks official.com right now holiday
season's coming they make great gifts
man we can do so much they got the ET
you know I mean they got the draws if
you already know odd Soxs making
underwear now and they're more
comfortable than all the other underwear
Brands let me be honest with you all
right they got all the licenses how
about Top Ramen underwear let me just
take a PE of these bad
boys see what we got here the ramen
draws baby what how about some Mountain
Dew Code Red Socks or or you know what
how about this how about we we keep the
soda theme going we got Mountain Dew
Baja Blast oh wait wait wait wait wait
we we we don't want either of those
we'll keep the soda thing going what
about some orange crush socks what if
you're fat like me you like chocolate
Hershey's they got WWE Breaking Bad
Godfather good I mean just all of the
damn things Power Rangers all the crazy
licenses go to oddsock official.com use
the promo code bootleg right now and you
will save 20% off odsx official.com
promo code bootleg save 20% off your
total order right now let's get back to
the
interviews crazy that [__] put some
[__] on the map I ain't going
to
lie was on there that's what I'm saying
that was one of my favorite albums I
mean songs bro like I had just got out
of uh I had just got out of jail bro
they just released me they like hey you
going home so right when they call my
name you feel me I take a piss I'm
washing my hands I get jumped on my way
out you feel me somebody from hover and
somebody from Inglewood they jumped me
on my way out you feel me it was cool I
wasn't tripping you feel me like it was
yeah it was nothing like I laughed on my
way out like good looking you feel me
feel me so um as soon as I came home bro
you know what was playing wster bro that
[__] was feel me so I'm like oh yeah
this something for the streets great cuz
you got to think about it the streets
was it was nothing for the streets
around that time think was J R and nelli
and yeah uh even though you had Snoop at
that time like Snoop was still doing
Snoop was [__] with for real you feel
me for real [__] for real was elevating
his sound you feel me so no but like
Snoop wasn't doing like like gangster
[__] at the time he was doing like big
hit records he was doing dropping like
it's hot and beautiful 2002 we was in
the streets bro we was in the streets so
anything that related to us we
gravitated to bro that's why the streets
ate all that G and the [__] up bro cuz
[__] was really in the streets 2002 it
was really we was outside for real were
people like in LA cuz I didn't live in
LA at the time but when like 50 in the
game had their split did like La fans
choose up bro it's funny that you
brought that up bro cuz I remember one
time we was out me and nip was supposed
to open up from Mob D mhm you know what
I mean and we had just seen game like 15
minutes before we went to the hotel you
feel me with them so we just chopping it
up about music whatever boom so we get
to the high Hotel you know that's across
the street from uh from the House of
Blues the Old House of Blues yeah mob
deep had a show that's when they was
signing gun you feel me so they had a
show at the uh House of Blues and me and
it was opening up for Mob deep so you
know we was [__] with this manager
dude named mod MH and you know he was
linked in with them you feel me
so we go to the hotel we up in there bro
it's like it's like 50 [__] from New
York you know what I mean all in the
hallway you feel me they get a call like
hey game downstairs you feel me so these
[__] go downstairs they like a 100
deep now I'm like godamn [__] coming
out of hotel rooms everywhere bro [__]
marching downstairs like you feel me so
uh you know it was just like a little
standoff or whatever you feel me I I I
tell nip I'm like hey nip what's up
[__] what you want to do like cuz you
see what's going on he like you feel me
we just going we just going to do us bro
like gang walked up to me he like he
asked me though he didn't ask nip he
asked he asked me he like hey y'all with
them [__] I'm like no I'm with the 60s
like he still remember that [__] still
to this day you feel me like like [__]
I'm with the 60s he like all right for
sure and then he walked away you feel me
then Su pull up sh pull up a red Beamer
jump out he walk right up the nip he
like nip what up he like [__] you know
you you see what's going on he like [__]
[__] what's up you feel me and then and
then [__] the police pull up soon yeah
soon the police P pulled up sh yeah he
pulled up and hopped out bro and in the
middle of the traffic bro on Sunset and
the red Beamer [__] with the red tents
jump out like what's happening like you
feel me but he walked right up to he
walked right up to me and nip you feel
me like what's up he like like [__] you
know I I let sh know what's going on he
like [__] what's up you feel me was sh
there like on behalf of game or was he
there on behalf of just was there on
behalf of whatever we said it was on
like he he understood the assignment you
feel me did you guys have a good
relationship with Su hell yeah yeah hell
yeah he'll see me and nip out a lot you
feel me he'll slide us a few bucks you
feel me to go [__] with him different
clubs and [__] shout out to sh man shout
out to started a podcast did you see
yeah I'm [__] with it it's called Uh
collect calls I think yeah shout out to
sh man I'm like more people need to do
podcast from jail if they can if they
can for sure Max B come on man you know
I got a record with Max B right do you
yeah oh that's hard yeah the wave God
shout for sure I think he'll be out soon
too they keep saying that yeah he coming
home you always got to have faith man
cuz even even even even even if the
outside thinking you or anybody thinking
you can't come home have that Faith bro
you going to come home for sure
yeah he's got a voicemail on a Kanye
album yeah so major shout out to hey Max
influenced a lot man come on yeah for
sure him St far as with that far as with
the harmonizing in your music for sure
like he was like one of the first dudes
man like for real it was like that was
considered a rapper obviously T pay was
around but like exactly the real like I
mean Bone Thugs the ogs I got to number
one oh yeah to Harmon Harmony yeah come
on just in terms of the street [__] it
was like really like Max B was probably
I mean he was before a future before all
those guys yeah facts he was doing a lot
of that [__] early man yeah shout out to
him man all right so the new album's
coming out on the 22nd um and then you
dropping on the first dropping on the
first bro so we got two albums on the
mayback music January 1st soon as a bar
drop I drop so that's the name of the
album mayback music uh no mayback season
I said mayack music yeah shout out to
Rick Ross hey shout out to Rick Ross May
season mayback season you ever regret by
your mayb back I thought about it and
then I'm like nah I don't what's the
insurance payment on that thing you know
it's it's it's a little pretty penny you
feel me but it was times while I was
riding with no Assurance what what Rick
Ross say I'm like how [__] got all
these M and riding but no Assurance
[__] no tags but I know what that feel
like bro trust me I know I know I know I
know what it feel like you feel me you
got to you don't have so you've ridden
with no insurance on the May I've have
before yeah oh that's [__] dangerous
I have before bro especially in LA but
I'm glad it didn't cost me for sure glad
it didn't cost me is the mayback heavier
than 6,000 lb it's not is it I'm just
thinking for tax purposes but see but no
but see you got to think about that too
for bulletproof purposes too cuz I know
you want to throw that on there you feel
me but like that [__] is it's
going to be heavy shout out to uh to the
mayback man so mayback season the first
definition of success November
22nd yeah November 22nd definition of
success the Final Chapter we closing it
out nipple be on there Bun B uh Trey the
truth I forgot some other people Nick
bucks Nick bucks um exhibit exhibit and
buch Cassidy on the same record you feel
me that sounds great that sounds like
2002 that's what I'm saying you feel me
I had to give him that classic West CO
bu Cassidy man [__] I ain't heard that
name in a minut yeah I had to give him
that West Coast but Cassidy on the
podcast classic Vibe yeah man get him up
here him cocaine yeah
yeah bro cuz you know they got they got
stories bro they been around the game
them fools voices are so hard I just
want to know what it was like behind the
scenes in them Studio sessions bro cuz
the music You Know the music was good
you hear the music what was dope too is
those guys were very much like a big
part of like post death row Snoop albums
yeah for sure you know cuz I feel like
last meal when when when when when Snoop
wasn't working with like um DZ And
Superfly he had go work with them and
get that sound too you know what I mean
and what was the other dude not
nocturnal was hard too yeah nocturnal
was hard man what happened nocturnal man
damn shout out to LA man love love hey
and we got to work on one of these We
Are the World La records that's why I'm
saying man we got to we got we got to
lift each other up man we can't let us
slip like that man you know ain't nobody
else letting their slip we can't let our
slip [__] all the politics [__] all that
[__] my [__] I love that attitude
uh there's going to be a lot he love
attitude but yeah [__] man more power to
it huh hey we'll see if it works out uh
2024 you're GNA be getting flooded with
J Stone flooded for sure for sure and
they better they better recognize it
they gonna act like they don't see it no
man you I see they going to have to they
going to have to give I buy all your
albums on iTunes when you drop I buy on
it they going to have to give me m bro
yeah and make sure you cop the [__]
album on iTunes yeah it helps yeah for
sure all that streaming [__] Spotify is
doing cool you feel me but like J Cole
said man he don't know who the [__]
buying all them damn albums but shout
out to the people that's doing it you
feel me like stra up there it is brother
well I appreciate you pulling up J Stone
new album on the way west west man boom
fire good [__] yo we're wrapping up an
interview man of course we want to shout
out to our family at harden baby Harden
Las Vegas celebrating their seventh
birthday this month so happy birthday to
harden uh want to give a shout out to
the whole family over there when you're
in Las Vegas you got to pull up the
Hardin tell them that the bootleg head
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders amazing
smoke just the illst merch you know what
I'm saying and it's right in Las Vegas
right in s City so you land in Vegas you
about to go gamble with your boys you
get in that cab you say take me to
harden they're going to know exactly
where to take you all right shout out to
Hardin go follow him Hardin Las Vegas or
go to the website Hardin vegas.com